God logic you're going to show me
nothing yeah you're going to show me
nothing cuz I know what the Quran says
yeah I'm a Muslim alhamdulillah you're
the puple I'm the teacher
[Music]
mate you don't know what Jesus said
where he went What miracles he did you
have no reliable sources of information
for this do do do you know where Jesus
went I don't need to I'm a Muslim mate
that's what I'm asking do you know where
Jesus I'm a Muslim why asking me why
would I care do you do you believe that
he's your Messiah do I believe he's my
Messiah yeah no so you don't believe
that Jesus is your so so who's the
messiah messiah was Jesus the Messiah
sent to the B is to the children of
Israel as he wait wait a second does
does not your Quran say that Jesus is a
sign for
mankind I believe Jesus is the Messiah
to the B Isel was he a sign for mankind
for the bani Isel Okay so maybe you're
unaware of this chapter 19 verse 21 it
says that Allah says that he made Jesus
a sign and a mercy for mankind chapter
21 verse that Jesus is
aind is he just for Israel or is he also
for okay Jesus was sent to the children
of Israel okay when he returns at the
end of days it will be For All Mankind
okay so when Jesus so when it says that
Jesus is a sign for
mankind is that only for Israel or is
that for everyone when Jesus first came
he was just for the children of Israel
when he returns he'll come to slay the
Dalal and for the and for all of mankind
where does your Quran say that when
Jesus first came he was only for Israel
where does your Quran say that we see we
said Isa son ofam is to the Ben is yeah
but where does it say only to Israel we
sent him to the B is being sent to
Israel doesn't excl exude everyone else
right well if you're being sent to B is
to the people of Israel children of
Israel yes it does that mean that you're
only for Israel well if you sent to the
children of Israel You're not sent to
the children of the Gentiles are you but
that doesn't mean just because you're
sent to like for example was Muhammad
sent to China no Muhammad sent for the
whole of mankind he was sent to the
whole of mankind but did he leave Arabia
he didn't need to he sent delegation to
Rome to Persia to Byzantium and called
them all to Islam got you so he himself
didn't have to go outside of Arabia for
his message to be for everyone else
right no no no no no no there's a
difference Allah says in the Quran we
sent you Muhammad as a Mercy to Mankind
s this is different and Muhammad peace
and acted upon that by sending a
delegation to Persia to Egypt and to
Rome calling them all to worship Allah
so therefore this is an indication and a
demonstration of his mission that he
wasn't just there for the Arabs he
called the Persians he called the
Egyptians now Jesus yeah didn't do that
Jesus was sent to the children of Israel
okay so even even according to what you
have left well even according to what
you have left the remnants The Echoes of
the life of Jesus yeah he clearly states
who he came for he clearly demonstrates
who he came for got you so all right so
let's talk about this what you just said
you said that Muhammad was For All
Mankind because and here was your
evidence is that the Quran says he's a
mercy for mankind and then you said that
Muhammad demonstrated what Allah has
said in the Quran by sending delegations
to these other nations that's what you
said so you have the claim from Allah
that proves that Muhammad is not just
for Arabia but For All Mankind and then
you have the
demonstation okay in the Quran it says
that Jesus is a mercy for mankind a sign
and a mercy for mankind so he wasn't
just for Israel by that standard he was
also for the rest of the world this is
what you me this is no this is what
you're mistaking okay when when the
Quran talks about Muhammad yeah Muhammad
is the final messenger there's no more
Messengers coming the new Shar is with
Muhammad the previous prophets now have
been surpassed just as Jesus surpassed
Moses and Muhammad surpassed Jesus okay
so when Allah speaks about Muhammad he's
the final messenger this is the messeng
of mankind when it's talking about Jesus
is it's past tense it's what's happened
in history kind of thing so we know as
Muslims or we believe as Muslims that
Jesus when he was sent had a mission to
go to the children of Israel to call
them back to worship and uh worship the
god of worship Allah and then afterwards
when they rejected him and such then
when he returns at the end of days to
slay the Antichrist yeah then he will be
for everybody obviously he's not just
going to come back for the Muslims he
gonna come back for everybody okay so
okay so that that's that's that okay so
again so you said that Muhammad is for
mankind because the Quran says he's a
mercy for mankind and then demonstrated
it
by sending delegates of of of his
message and The Message of Islam to
these different nations and different
people so what you have here is you have
where Jesus according to your Quran is
sent to Israel but is also said to be a
signed and a mercy for
mankind so the same way that you believe
that Muhammad is for mankind the Quran
says the same thing about Jesus which is
why you should know where Jesus preached
the Messiah what he did what was in his
message no don't we don't need to know
these
things is he not your Messiah okay no
he's not my Messiah no okay he's not
your Messiah that's tough no he's not
where do you get this idea that he's not
your Messiah because he was sent to the
children of Israel as their Messiah wa
okay who was promised the Messiah who
was promised the Messiah at any point
who was promised the Messiah Jesus sto
being Messi one second who prom no h
this is the question does Jesus stop
being the Messiah at some point who was
promised the Messiah Jesus is no who was
promised who was promised they would be
sent the Messiah everyone where does not
everyone the Gentiles too where does it
say that in Isaiah 49 what does it say
in Isaiah 49:6 it says talking about the
Messiah it's too small a thing that I
should uh make you my servant to raise
up the tribes of Jacob and to bring back
the preserved of Israel but I will also
make you Al light to the Gentiles that
my salvation May reach the ends of the
Earth so both Gentiles and the
Israelites are promised the Messiah so
so you're saying to me when the Jews
read their Old Testament they they
recognize a messiah that's going to be
sent to the Gentiles yes he's not just
for Israel he's also no they don't no
they don't they don't they don't
interpret the way you interpret it well
well guess what when when when when the
when the Hebrews when when some of the
Jews read their text and they and they
see that Jesus is not the Messiah does
that make it there are they in Authority
no no the the point is this the point is
this you're just interpreting a verse to
suit your narrative because your
understanding of the Messiah has been
warped by the trinitarian concept of a
messiah wait who's the the Jews the Jews
do you believe in the time of Jesus
right one second how did the Jews
understand this term Messiah no no one
second one second no no it matters it
matters it matters in the time of Jesus
what is the standard in the time of
Jesus when he was preaching no that's
not the question no no but we're
establishing the position of the word
Messiah isn't it so no no we're not what
we are because when you say Messiah when
you say Messiah and I say Messiah we're
talking about two different things no so
when you when you said when you said who
was promised the Messiah and you and I
told you who and I gave you the verse
you you you then said wait do the Jews
think this when they read this why are
you why are you appealing to them I'll
explain to you okay okay the term
Messiah in the time of Jesus is not what
you think Messiah is it was a completely
different understanding
yeah the Jews were not waiting for some
um somebody to come for the whole world
they were waiting for their Messiah
their Jewish Messiah the reestablishment
of Jewish monarchy this is what they're
waiting for this is why the Pharisees
didn't have a problem with Jesus
claiming to be the Messiah because they
were waiting for the Messiah there's no
issues of being a messiah yeah it just
means the reestablishment of Jewish
monarchy which was abolished by the
Romans yeah but when you Christians get
hold of the word Messiah and you take it
into this kind of Savior for the whole
world through the death and resurrection
and search this is the your lens you're
coming through so when you see the ter
so when you see the term Messiah it's
not your Messiah okay so touch on this
then I gave you the verse where it talks
about the Messiah being for both
Israelites and Gentiles so break that
down for me when it says which verse is
it okay it's Isaiah chapter 49 okay
verse six one
second one
second Isaiah 49 verse 6 verse 6 and
this is is uh
okay I can't believe you said Jesus is
not your Messiah that's wild yeah he's
not it's tough
man give me a
second he can't he can't defend
Christianity we're doing it right now
this is not Christian offending me you
you you're already you've already
conceded that your authors of your
gospels are Anonymous and yet you
believe what they say yes she did I
never conceded that at all yes she yes
she did you said so what so we're yours
yes she did you said what about is I
never conceded it I literally said okay
are are the authors of the gospels
Anonymous yeah I told them I'm showing
them the inconsistency but are they are
the authors of the gospels Anonymous no
or not they're not who wrote the Book of
Mark yeah we'll get into that in a
second but Mark just who's Mark who's
Mark Mark D no who's Mark we we'll we'll
let you we're not no who who's who's
this right to Mark who is it I want you
to focus focus on 49 I am I am I am one
second one second
okay that might work on other Christians
it doesn't work here what you about the
the little deflections and stuff there
is no deflections basically you you
you've just said you don't believe the
authors are Anonymous correct yeah right
but with the other Muslim guy you said I
so what so were yours yeah so is that
that's not a concession
right by Way say
say I didn't
say I didn't say so what so are yours
have to say exactly words go with you I
said let me go with you all right let me
go with you on that one second one
second and I just showed him how
inconsistent his position is it doesn't
really matter because if your position
um can't be Justified whether someone
else's can or not doesn't strengthen
your own position yeah I'm here to
demonstrate to you you've got no legs to
stand on me all right well let's let's
see come on man it don't take that long
to find the verse Oh it it does it's not
about finding the verse look I'm not I'm
not a Jew I don't know where they
understand this verse I'm going to read
where they understand it it's their book
wait wait so you're not reading the
verse I'm going to look at the verse and
look how it's been understood you look
you've read the verse and understood it
how you've chosen to understand it yeah
I've I've chosen to understand it how it
reads that's read it again read it again
okay so here it
is you're looking at it or you looking
at interpretation what are you looking
at I'm looking at it I'm looking at the
how the can you read it oh okay listen
to me there's no point me just reading
it yeah yes it is I want you to just
read no it's not no no no no look look I
could read the text as you read the text
and then you can tell me me man I I
don't know why that we're laughing for
all right so this is I'm a Muslim yeah
is this book my book no is this book the
book of the Jew yes it is your book
actually how is this my book you're a
Muslim you can't you have to believe in
the books don't you which books which
books all of them all that was been
revealed by before the Quran this wasn't
revealed oh Lord okay it wasn't revealed
no wor do you think the do you think the
Old Testament
496 I'm not going to allow you just to
say look can you just read the I I think
there's been a misom you know I don't
believe the Old Testament and New
Testament Revelation don't you no words
no but you know that don't you I I
understand that right so when you say to
me when I when I say to
you one second no I'm not okay where
does my Quran say I have to believe in
the Old
Testament all over the place we'll get
there I promise no no it doesn't it
doesn't but I I'll show you all of that
okay God logic you're going to show me
nothing yeah you're going to show me
nothing cuz I know what the Quran says
yeah I'm a Muslim alhamdulillah you
think you know
what you think you know what the Quran
says I'm the shake I'm gonna show you
what your Quran says I'm the you're
you're the pupil I'm the teacher mate
okay we'll see can you read the verse
yeah I'm I'm reading it now okay so this
is and he said so this is one second
come on man it doesn't take long okay so
149 listen o ises unto me and hearken ye
people for far the Lord ha called me
from the womb so you think this is Jesus
being spoken about yeah of course it's
the Messiah the bowels of my mother ha
he made mention of my name and he have
made me my mouth like a sharp sword in
the shadow of his hand hath he hid me
and made me a polished shaft in his quer
have he hid me and said unto me thou art
my servant oh Israel
whoa that's Jacob no it's not who is
Israel that's the Messiah Thou Art my
servant oh Israel keep reading no he
well I'm I'm reading it thou are my
servant o Israel So it's talking about
Jacob one second who Messiah you're
about to see who who is Israel who is
Israel I'm I'm about to show you you
have Israel you have the individual
Israel who's the messiah who represents
Israel then you have Israel the nation
who that individual say okay so let me
just read this again this is Isaiah
speaking Yeah and Heath made so so this
is what uh this is Isiah speaking
prophetically with the Messiah right
right right right so this is this is um
him speaking Yeah listen oh Isles unto
me and hearken ye people the Lord hath
called me from the
womb okay so you think this is Jesus
speaking yeah yes okay so this is let's
imagine this is Jesus speaking from the
bowels of my mother hath he me mentioned
me and Heath made me my mouth like a
sharp sword in the shadow of his hand
hath he hid me and made me a polished
shaft in his quiver hath he hid me and
said unto me thou art my servant so now
this means God has said to Jesus thou my
servant oh Israel correct well Jesus is
not Israel Jesus is Israel no Jesus is
not Jacob is Israel okay keep reading
we're gonna I'm G to show right so in
context it's talking about Jacob not
Israel it's not it's talking about the
Messiah who was identified as Israel
Well it can't it can't be where God is
saying to this per individual Thou Art
my servant or Israel okay just if I
promise you Hamza it all gets cleared up
if you just keep reading I promise okay
then I have labored in vain I have spent
my strength for not and in vain yet
surely my judgment is with the Lord and
my work with God so God is GNA judge
this person yeah no he's not GNA judge
this person he approves him my judgment
is with the Lord meaning what does that
even me means his approval means it
means I'll be judged by God no okay it's
it is I'll yet surely my judgment is
with the Lord and my work and my work
with my God does Jesus have a God just
just keep going yeah father according to
his flesh yeah so so the father is the
god of Jesus correct according to so you
believe God has a god according to the
Flesh of course what does jiah 32:27 God
is the God of All Flesh Jesus who is God
also took on flesh without the flesh
without the flesh the father became his
God oh and without the flesh without
he's not he's not the god of Jesus over
his divine nature they have the same so
without the flesh what is he they are so
there's two natures
and so you have the father then the son
who share the same Divine Essence
therefore God the Father can't be God
over his divine nature what you mean two
Natures who's got two Natures the sun
does but you're you're deflecting again
no no no no no look we are we here being
honest here are we trying to understand
things here right right right right
right so what you can't do what you
can't do is just say things to support
your argument no no not all I'm not I'm
not saying you're asking questions that
are
un incarnation no no what I'm saying is
your whole position is based on your
assumptions which don't hold up to
scrutiny what I don't have any
assumptions here at all yes you do
telling you I'm telling you now I've
just read did you just read you got it
I've just read three chapters so far and
this can't be referring to Jes verses
you read three verses I've read three
chapters yeah I started at 491 uh 49 and
I'm at 493 494 now I've read four
chapters and so far four verses four
verses yeah four chapters sorry yeah
four paragraphs four paragraphs yeah
yeah so what I'm saying so far this is
not about Jesus anyway let me continue
well keep going and now said the
Lord that formed me from the womb to be
his servant to bring ja Jacob again to
him to bring who Jacob wait I thought I
thought that was
Jacob one second
H I thought that was
Jacob but look look can I can I make
something very very plain to you sure
this this Old Testament yeah
it makes many many mistakes errors it's
well it does it does okay well no no I
don't know why you're laughing it does
it doesn't get chronology right
sometimes it gets the stories back to
front sometime it it messes up it
doesn't Okay I I tell you why it does
because it's contradicted itself already
really so it doesn't surprise me yes of
course it has okay so so so so the
person who's Israel is supposed to bring
back Jacob so he's not Jacob himself
right
okay you're the pupil I'm the teacher
mate you're the pupil I'm the teacher
mate oh my
[Music]
godic